et lui pour le coup il est ingrat parce
que quand il a fait de la promo pour sa
pièce de théâtre je les ai reçus très
amicalement et très gentiment à
plusieurs reprises aux grosses têtes lui
et sa compagne
donc je vois pas pourquoi c'est bien à
balancer ça parce que j'ai pas les même
si des polluants que lui ça c'est
certain
c'est ça qu'ils dérangent et
d'intolérance de sa part mais pas de la
mienne s'était pas jean michel willot
rond vous avez fait une remarque
malicieuse sur les candidats gays tout à
l'heure de l'amour est dans le pré qui
sont très bonnes à bout voilà donc je
vais savoir puisque vous avez fait votre
coming out dans les médias il ya
quelques temps
pourquoi ça a été un poids médias moi je
les fais sur scène et attrait non pas
dans les années 80 après dans les médias
ça a été un peu officialisé enfin pour
ceux qui aiment et pas subi le théâtre
en tout cas pourquoi ça va être c'était
important pour vous de l'avoir fait et
comment vous l'avez vécue parce que je
me sentais mieux dans mes bottes après
l'avoir dit dans les années 90 c'est
vrai que c'était plutôt gonflé à
l'époque passer quoi on n'était pas
nombreux à y faire et voilà mais en même
temps j'ai jamais au mieux reproche
d'ailleurs la communauté game leurs
proches parfois j'ai jamais été
communautariste militants peut-être à
tort d'ailleurs parce que c'est vrai on
me le dit souvent mais alors c'est trop
facile vous profitez des avantages que
les militants c'est la discussion que
j'ai eue avec alice coffin j'ai trouvé
très intéressante de cette discussion
samedi dernier mais voilà j'en fais pas
un étendard mais je ne veux pas non plus
caché je cache ma vie privée en général
de toute façon mais je serai hétéro ce
serait exactement la même chose
hétéro homo pour moi c'est la même chose
maintenant je venais pas mentir sur qui
j'étais sultan